in der phoenix runde
phoenix runde
schönen guten abend ganz herzlich
willkommen aus berlin zu dieser ersten
phoenix runde im neuen jahr zu dem wir
uns wohl alle am ehesten vor allem
gesundheit wünschen ich darf in meine
gäste vorstellen dr andreas gassen ist
da vorsitzender der kassenärztlichen
bundesvereinigung und bei uns ist auch
eva quadbeck stellvertretende
chefredakteurin und leiterin des
hauptstadtbüros des redaktions netzwerks
deutschland rnd
zugeschaltet ist sonst professor susanne
schreiber sie ist die stellvertretende
vorsitzende des ethikrates schon guten
abend und professor dr christian fester
lotzer rechtswissenschaftler und
mitglied der ethikkommission der
ärztekammer berlin und auch der ethik
kommission des landes berlin guten abend
herr gassen und versuchen wir es mal ein
bisschen zusammen zu fassen wir hätten
vor zwei jahren natürlich nicht gedacht
dass wir hier immer noch so sitzen und
auch letztes jahr nicht wo stehen wir
jetzt zu beginn dieses jahres was die
krone pandemie anbetrifft
würden sie sagen an welchem punkt sind
wir ja gut vielleicht kann man es am
ehesten so zusammenfassen wir nähern uns
wahrscheinlich langsam tatsächlich der
endemischen situation das heißt noch
einige monate und dann wären wir
vielleicht eine normalisierung der
situation erfahren im moment steigen das
ist sozusagen normales
krankheitsgeschehen ist corona wie
beispielsweise in prenzlau und viele
andere erkrankung im moment steigen die
zahlen hallt wider
erwarten bei micon sie sind fast im
anstieg relativ niedrig wir hätten
eigentlich steilere anstiege erwartet
wenn man in großbritannien und viele
andere länder sieht grund mag sein dass
da vielleicht mehr getestet wird das mag
schlechter und zum teil an den maßnahmen
liegen und dass sie sicherlich auch an
der doch gar nicht so schlechten quote
in deutschland da heißt es immer die
zahlen sind eigentlich gar nicht so
belastbar wenn man nicht mit den
feiertagen nicht getestet hat also der
ist doch irgendwas auf welcher basis
haben wir eigentlich jetzt dieses wir
haben gar keine gute datenbasis man
sagen ob ich sagen das ist immer so ein
bisschen momentaufnahme vor den
feiertagen haben wir alle an die
schlangen vor den testzentren erinnern
können weil alle die ihre angehörigen
besucht haben natürlich eher mehr
getestet haben insofern glaube ich sind
die zahlen nur begrenzt belastbar
wichtiger ist natürlich wie es die
krankheitslast wie sie es auf
intensivstation den krankenhäusern aus
da scheint sich gewisse entspannung
abzeichnen ob das belastbar ist ob das
jetzt auch tatsächlich weiter so geht
muss man sehen sicherlich noch zu früh
um entwarnung zu geben
aber insgesamt
glauben wir ja schon das zum frühjahr
sommer hin sich die situation weiter
entspannt und nikon möglicherweise die
chance dafür ist aus dieser mann de
mission situation rauszukommen
das wäre dann ein bisschen nach einem
hoffnungsschimmer für dieses jahr 2022
und hat natürlich dann auch mit der das
wirkt sich auch auf die diskussion über
die kosten reden wir dann gleich drüber
frau quadbeck jetzt haben wir letzte
woche neue strengere umgangsregelung
gehabt bekommen von in der bund länder
konferenz wurde wieder einiges
beschlossen haben sie das gefühl dass
die politik gerade die führung gibt die
so viele gerne haben möchten in dieser
krise und von der bundeskanzler gesagt
hat wer sie bei ihm bestellt der das ja
sie auch bekommt nein auf mich hat diese
veranstaltung in der vergangenen woche
sehr ratlos gewirkt und es waren ja auch
eher kleinere veränderungen vorgenommen
wurden sind auf der einen seite ist die
karenzzeit verkürzt worden was man ja
streng genommen als lockerung bezeichnen
kann mit dem hinweis dass eben die zeit
in der man ansteckend ist kürzer ist bei
omikron wobei wir auch die data variante
noch haben und dann auf der anderen
seite die 2g plus regelung für die
gastwirtschaft für gaststätten die aber
bisher noch gar nicht wirklich umgesetzt
ist also ungefähr die hälfte der
bundesländer hat sie jetzt eingeführt
manche wollen sie gar nicht einführen
aber auch also auch da haben wir zwar
eine neue regierung aber alte probleme
nämlich dass nach einer
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz jedes land
dann erst mal guckt wie er sich doch
alleine dadurch navigiert und haben sie
den eindruck dass der bundeskanzler dass
ganz angenehm findet oder dass er
eigentlich gerne mehr da führen möchte
also der bundeskanzler hat sich ja für
eine impfpflicht ausgesprochen aber an
der stelle wirkt er dann doch sehr
machtlos weil er sie nicht umsetzen kann
und weil er auch keine ampel mehrheit
hat um sie umzusetzen und ansonsten ist
scholz ja jemand der eigentlich noch
stärker als merkel nicht in die
offensive geht sondern erst einmal
schaut was überhaupt machbar ist und
dann auch ganz gern schon mal die tube
weiße salbe rausholt und sie über die
probleme darüber denkt okay da kommen
wir gleich mal wenn wir intensiv über
die impfpflicht sprechen aber frau
schreiber an sie die frage wie empfinden
sie die kommunikation die im moment wo
jetzt alle so mühe sind von dieser
pandemie und das gefühl haben eigentlich
können wir gar nicht mehr hören hatten
alle gesetz auf die impfung sehen jetzt
haben wir diese neue variante also es
ist eben alles wieder alles ein bisschen
anders wie empfinden sie gerade die
kommunikation durch die politik für die
bürger
ja ich würde sagen man merkt dass auch
die politik immer noch etwas ratlos ist
wie wir jetzt wirklich vorgehen sollen
ist es ja auch wirklich schwierig weil
wir in einer umbruchphase sind zwischen
zwei verschiedenen varianten des virus
zwischen der delta variante und die
omikron variante wo wir wieder neue
unsicherheitsfaktoren haben weil wir
noch nicht ganz genau wissen wie schwer
wird die erkrankung sein wie ansteckend
ist das hat sich jetzt alles erst in den
letzten wochen begonnen abzuzeichnen und
diese ganze unsicherheit dem merkt man
auch bei der politik und das ist
natürlich nicht schön also auch ich
würde mir wünschen dass dort mehr mit
einer stimme gesprochen wird und wer
denken sie müsste mehr für diese eine
stimme werben
naja es ist unser aller aufgabe sich die
wissenschaft muss ihren beitrag leisten
die politiker geschäften beschäftigen
sich ja damit aber es ist schon wichtig
dass wir dieses ganze hin und her was ja
manchmal sich gar nicht vermeiden lässt
weil wir das wissen wirklich noch nicht
haben aber dass man das doch auch so
kommuniziert dass es transparenter ist
und dass man nicht den eindruck hat auch
es wird hier ständig hü und hott und es
gibt eigentlich gar kein planen dabei
ich glaube schon dass es einen plan gibt
und dass auch politiker sehr
gewissenhaft mit den informationen
umgehen trotzdem muss man gerade in so
einer situation noch besonders gut drauf
achten wie es vermittelt wird damit eben
bei der bevölkerung auch nicht der
eindruck entsteht ist also willkürlich
die frage ist ob es wirklich einen plan
gibt was die impfpflicht betrifft der
pestalozzi haben in einer phoenix runde
im november zum thema endlich haben sie
gesagt man muss doch davon ausgehen dass
es einen gesetzentwurf schon in der
schublade gibt und wenn man ihn dann
braucht dann muss man ihn raus holen den
eindruck hat man jetzt nicht dass da
irgendwas in der schublade liegt wie
empfinden sie das agieren jetzt auch
gerade rund um die impfpflicht
es kommt mir wie eine frühere aktion
auch ziemlich dilettantisch vor
was ich nicht verstehe ist muss ja
unterscheiden wenn man an die
impfpflicht denkt
dass man eine regelung trifft und die
zweite frage ist wann wird diese
regelung in kraft gesetzt womit man
nicht warten sollte ist mit einer
regelung mit dem in kraft setzen kann
man dann vielleicht noch zu warten aber
die regelung müsste längst da sein und
sie ist nicht darauf und der bundestag
beginnt jetzt offenbar darüber
nachzudenken das finde ich ein bisschen
spät ich sage nicht dass die impfpflicht
heute kommen müsste die allgemeine
impfpflicht das hängt auch vom
medizinischem rat ab und von der
einschätzung der neuen varianten und der
jenen die noch kommen mögen aber die
regelung müsste vorrätig sein so dass
mit einer entscheidung mit einem
beschluss des bundestages oder gemeinsam
des bundestages und bundesrates die
dinge in kraft gesetzt werden können man
kann nicht jetzt anfangen über die
rechtlichen implikationen der
impfpflicht nachzudenken dass es zu spät
ist es denn inzwischen einfach mehr ein
parteipolitisches spiel geworden oder
geht es wirklich um die bekämpfung des
virus frau quadbeck bei der impfpflicht
bei der diskussion also die debatte um
die impfpflicht ist inzwischen zu einer
parteipolitischen taktik verkommen das
ist eine ausgesprochen verlogene debatte
viele spitzenpolitiker haben sich für
eine impfpflicht ausgesprochen nachdem
er hoch und heilig versprochen worden es
wird keine impfpflicht kommen in
deutschland das darf man in dieser
debatte eben auch nicht vergessen und
deshalb ist die politische fallhöhe
jetzt besonders groß und wir haben in
den nächsten im nächsten halben jahr
drei landtagswahlen vor der brust und
der verfahren die politiker jetzt nach
dem motto wasch mir den pelz aber mach
mich nicht nass also viele wollen die
impfpflicht aber sie wollen am ende
nicht dafür verantwortlich sein und dann
kommt noch hinzu dass das was die fdp
gerne gehabt hätte nämlich dass die
impfpflicht als fraktions offene
abstimmung im bundestag durchgesetzt
wird also man stimmt nicht nach
fraktionen regierung opposition ab
sondern jeder abgeordnete stimmt nach
dem gesetzentwurf den er genau nach
seinem gewissen für richtig hält dann
macht die union eben nicht mit das es
auch vorher nicht so abgesprochen wurden
aber natürlich taktiert die union weil
auch ihre spitzenpolitiker und die
mehrheit in der fraktion sich für eine
impfpflicht ausgesprochen hat und steht
jetzt auf der bremse blockiert alles und
die ampel wie ich gerade ja schon gesagt
habe hat keine eigene mehrheit
insbesondere weil die fdp nicht mitgeht
wie sinnvoll ist denn dann überhaupt
noch eine nebenpflicht wenn das man
merkt das ist so ein spiel gewonnen von
den parteien sorgt für verunsicherungen
herr gassen wie sinnvoll sagen sie ist
eine impfpflicht im kampf gegen korona
also juristisch will ich das gar nicht
bewerten das kann ich auch nicht die
frage ist immer wie diese sinnvoll aus
medizinischer sicht würden wir bei einer
impfpflicht immer wünschen dass einige
faktoren erfüllt also einmal würde man
erwarten dass das virus was diese
erkrankung macht damit ausgelöscht
ausgerottet wird das ist zum beispiel
poppen gelungen zum zweiten würde man
sich natürlich eine herdenimmunität
wünschen euch die impfung und
idealerweise eine lebenslange immunität
für das individuum alle diese drei
punkte werden balkone nicht erfüllt
durch die impfung das muss man leider
sagen deshalb und was möchte ich
vorausschicken ich trotzdem großer fan
und befürworter der impfung das sollte
man als erwachsener mensch auf jeden
fall tun und ich bin auch dafür die
musterung zu machen aber ich glaube die
impfpflicht würde hier keine
verbesserung der impfquote bewirken wir
haben eine impfquote die beiden über 60
jahren bei 88,4 prozent liegt also so
schlecht war über 60 jährigen das sind
ja auch die im wesentlichen gefährdeten
und selbst darunter liegt deutlich über
70 prozent wir haben immer noch sieben
millionen genesene und man muss ja sehen
welche organisatorischen
herausforderungen so eine impfpflicht zu
stellen wir müssen erstmal ins register
haben das haben wir nicht wir müssen ein
leitungssystem an wir müssen ein festes
impfschema haben wir müssen einen
impfstoff haben der gegen die aktuellen
varianten wirksam wird der müsste
überall verfügbar sein wer lädt ein wer
kontrolliert das gilt wer impft und wer
momentan also es gibt eine ganze
vielzahl von organisatorischen fallen
und wenn ich mir anschaue dann nicht mal
eine vernünftige datenlage so zahl der
geimpften genesen und der aktuellen
krankheitssituation haben dann frage ich
mich ernsthaft wie er das machen soll
und von daher glaube ich ist die
politische gigantisch die impfpflicht
wird aus meiner sicht praktikabel kaum
umzusetzen sein wenn die diskussion ist
noch zwei drei monate dauert werden wir
sie auch nicht mehr brauchen weil dann
sind wir im sommer haben wir
möglicherweise schon eine endemische
situation oder wir haben wieder noch ein
das video ist was vielleicht irgendwann
aktuell ohnehin nicht also von daher
müsste man eigentlich mehr in zeit und
geld und werfe investieren um die
menschen die noch überzeugt sind von dem
vorteil der impfung zu überzeugen dass
ich wenn er das eine tun das andere
nicht lassen der ethikrat hat sich ja
mehrheitlich dann nicht einstimmig
überhaupt nicht aber doch mit dem mit
einer mehrheit für die impfpflicht
ausgesprochen frau schreiber warum was
waren die hauptargumente derjenigen die
gesagt haben doch was macht sinn dass
wir eine allgemeine impfpflicht bekommen
also der ethikrat hat sich mit 20 von
seinen 24 mitgliedern also schon einer
sehr breiten mehrheit dafür
ausgesprochen dass die impfpflicht so
wie wir sie jetzt haben aktuell
einrichtungs bezogen haben dass die noch
etwas weiter ausgeweitet wird ja wir
haben diese beratung gemacht im dezember
wo auch noch delta vorher schon war auch
wenn wir am mikro sozusagen schon am
horizont sehen konnten und es gibt
einige argument also das was im dezember
auch besonders offensichtlich wo ist
dass wir die überlastung des
gesundheitssystems eben zu manchen
zeitpunkt der pandemie doch fürchten
mussten das haben wir im dezember sehr
sehr stark gespürt und das ist der grund
der hauptgrund wo wir gesagt haben okay
wenn das wirklich so stark wird dass
auch die krankenhäuser nicht mehr
richtig arbeiten können das normale
patienten die kommen mit normal meine
ich jetzt herzinfarktpatienten
schlaganfallpatienten und so weiter die
auch nicht unbedingt krone haben müssen
dass die nicht mehr behandelt werden
können dann ist das ein so hohes gut
unser gesundheitssystem das wir schützen
müssen und dass das dann zu solchen
zeitpunkten auch der punkt erreicht ist
wo wie die impfquote eben mit anderen
mitteln gegebenenfalls erhöhen müssen
wenn es freiwillig nicht geht darum hat
der ethikrat in der stellungnahme sehr
differenziert dargestellt was dafür und
was dagegen spricht und zum damaligen
zeitpunkt haben also kurz vor
weihnachten auch quasi eine abstimmung
vorgenommen und haben quasi 20
mitglieder gesagt manche haben sich
ausgesprochen für eine impfpflicht für
generale personen also für die
risikogruppen und für ältere patienten
und ein teil des ethikrates hat sich
ausgesprochen für eine allgemeine
impfpflicht also für alle über 18 und
gab es denn auch dann ideen darüber wie
man das dann umsetzt das hat der gassen
gerade gesagt das ist dann so schwierig
ist es ist ja kein impfzwang vielleicht
muss man das auch noch mal da machen es
wird ja niemand sozusagen abgeholt und
der zwang geimpft das ist ja vielleicht
anderem eine wichtige unterscheidung
ganz genau also das ist uns wirklich
sehr sehr wichtig dass kein impfzwang
besteht dass also keine gewalt oder
irgendwie angewendet wird und jemand das
wirklich gezwungen wird die impfung zu
erhalten man kann sich aber schon
vorstellen dass es über bußgelder
geregelt wird das also ist auch in
irgendeiner art und weise konsequenzen
gibt wenn man sich nicht impfen lassen
möchte aber zwang gehört definitiv nicht
dazu und sie hatten jetzt noch ganze
noch ganz kurz an den anderen teil ihrer
frage erinnern da habe antworte ich den
auch noch gerne also wie man es umsetzen
will weil das hat er gesagt gibt sagt ja
die ideen darüber
dass man gut einsetzen kann
genau das war auch etwas was wir also
sehr differenziert dargestellt haben
dass die umsetzung wirklich ein
kritischer punkt ist da gibt es
rechtliche probleme die es zu lösen gilt
die kann ich jetzt hier aber auch nicht
eingehen also das ist auch nicht ganz
meine expertise ist aber es ist
schwierig also muss sich gedanken
darüber machen gibt es zum beispiel die
möglichkeit der inhaftierung oder nicht
ich persönlich finde das nicht gut wenn
bei einer impfpflicht es zu einer
inhaftierung führen würde wenn man es
verweigert es müssen aber eben auch die
voraussetzungen erfüllt sein und das hat
herr gasse neben ja schon sehr schön
dargestellt ist muss genug impfstoff
vorhanden sein muss muss die ganze
logistik stimmen mai nimmt register wäre
wünschenswert also all diese dinge sind
voraussetzungen so dass wir jetzt
ethikrat also auch sehr hohe maßstäbe
angelegt haben an eine solche
impfpflicht wenn sie denn kommen würde
der pestalozzi wie
wichtig ist es dass das rechtlich ja
dann eben ganz ganz sicher ist weil wenn
man sagt ein argument ist zum beispiel
die belastung des gesundheitssystem dann
könnten ja die gegner der impfpflicht
sagen dann soll man doch dafür sorgen
dass es in den krankenhäusern nicht so
hohen belastungen kommt das ist doch
dann kein grund die körperliche
unversehrtheit in frage zu stellen also
wo sehen sie da knackpunkt oder
schwierigkeiten dass man sagt dass man
dann nicht letztendlich dann gegen die
impfpflicht klagt und dann hat keiner
etwas gewonnen
naja
eine klage sollten wir einen pflicht
haben würde in jedem fall kommen und das
ist das gute recht jedes betroffenen
bürgers und davor sollte man nicht
zurückschrecken dann dürfte man
überhaupt keine das nahmen die irgendwie
in grundrechte eingreifen wegen auch die
impfpflicht nicht also dafür davor kann
man dafür keine sorge haben im gegenteil
ich bin immer froh wenn das
bundesverfassungsgericht insbesondere
angerufen wird weil dann haben wir in
kürzerer oder längerer zeit eben ein
letztes wort aus rechtlicher sicht
jedenfalls und das gibt dann der politik
eine gewisse richtung vor also das sehe
ich als positives das auf eine regelung
auch eine klage folgen kann das ist kein
grund die regelung nicht zutreffen die
frage ist nur welche regelung kann man
treffen oder sollte man treffen und da
hängen die juristen natürlich von den
medizinischen auskünften und dem stand
der pandemie stark ab sie können dann
nur an diese auskünfte sich reinhängen
und sagen gut unter diesen umständen
macht eine impfpflicht sinnen oder macht
keine impfpflicht sehen wenn wir zum
beispiel feststellen sollten dass gegen
neue varianten die bisher führenden
impfstoffe nicht wirken dann können sich
natürlich keine verpflichtung einführen
sich mit diesen stoffen impfen zu lassen
das ist ganz klar also die juristen
stehen in der zweiten linie und müssen
reagieren auf das was medizinischer
erkenntnis ist aber sie sollten die
denkbaren regelungen ich habe es vorhin
schon mal gesagt in der schublade haben
damit dass er ganz ganz schwer es wäre
was in der schublade zu haben wenn man
nicht weiß ob sie dass sich die basis
aufgrund dessen man ein entwurf plant ja
dann wieder verändert also wenn sie
sagen die juristen stehen in der zweiten
reihe die wissenschaftler sind davon
aber die die basis ist ja immer wieder
eine andere frau blick also das ist ja
ganz schwierig dann daraus ich dann auch
zu reagieren ich frage mich ob man aus
dieser entweder ohne debatte raus muss
also entweder impfpflicht oder keine
impfpflicht also entweder sowie herr
gassen sagt nur
kampagne fahren oder eben impfpflicht
110 frage mich ob man nicht einfach die
2g regel sehr viel verbindlicher und
umfassender machen kann dass man sagt in
überall dort wo jetzt drei geld gilt hat
künftig zweig und zwar solange wir in
der pandemischen lage sind und in dem
moment in dem wir in der md mission lage
sind also die experten sagen wir haben
keine pandemie mehr dass das in dem
moment auch aufgehoben ist und 2g würde
bedeuten dass man das auch am
arbeitsplatz hat dass man das in
öffentlichen verkehrsmitteln hat und
dass man das eben überall hat wo
menschen zusammen gekommen sind und dann
müsste man geimpft seien nach dem
aktuellen stand der empfehlung der stiko
und wenn wir jetzt sagen den impfstoff
den wir im moment haben er wirkt nur
mittelmäßig gegen omikron dann
muss man zumindest sag ich mal wenn die
wissenschaftler noch empfehlen zu sagen
dass boostern lohnt sich weil es eben
gegen omikron wirkt dann sollte das der
stand der dinge seien natürlich auch
immer aber bekannt dass zwei gehen nicht
nur erst machen wenn ich dann
letztendlich alle gewusst habe naja man
kann auch sagen man kann es ja mit
fristen einführen man kann ja sagen bis
dann und dann muss das geschehen sein
man kann es natürlich nicht von heute
auf morgen einführen sondern das kann
man natürlich nur mit fristen einführen
um den leuten die chance zu geben ihre
impfungen noch nachzuholen oder sich auf
den stand zu bringen und da ja auch alle
geimpft werden müssen muss das immer ein
korridor sein das ist klar aber wäre das
eine art dann letztendlich impfpflicht
durch die hintertür dass man nicht auch
wieder licht hat aber eigentlich
individualisiert ausgeschlossen von dem
ich muss vor gericht geben man hat in
satz zwei gehe jetzt erst mal ausgerufen
und irgendwie wird es nicht exekutiert
und wir erleben ja schon zweig plus was
diskutiert wie gastronomie wird beispiel
das interessanterweise in bayern nicht
umgesetzt die immer für die härtesten
maßnahmen sind also insofern glaube ich
das wäre schon ein praktikabler weg das
ist auch sich ja nicht nicht nach
jedermanns geschmack aber damit würde
ich der zweck erfüllt dass man sagt man
schützt die umkämpft weil die können
dann eben sich potenziell riskanten
aktivität nicht mehr aussetzen und hat
trotzdem keine
endlich es geht ja also mir für mich
wäre eigentlich entscheiden wie bekommen
wir die meisten leute zur impfung und
ich glaube tatsächlich dass die
impfpflicht uns gar nicht wirklich
weiterbringt die impfung ist sicherlich
im moment das klügste was man machen
kann zum individual schutz das muss man
betonen herdenschutz gibt es dadurch
nicht und solange nichts besseres haben
sind die fahrenden impfstoffe eben in
einer musterung sicherlich sinnvoll und
das glaube ich ist die frage wie kriegt
man möglichst viele menschen überzeugen
ich glaube tatsächlich dieses hin und
her ist nicht besonders förderlich und
natürlich reiht sich auch die
impfpflicht wieder in die reihe der
gebrochenen versprechen ein was auch
nicht gerade zur glaubwürdigkeit mal
drückt aber hätte es keine alternative
gegeben man wusste doch im letzten ihr
anfang 2020 als man das alles aus kassel
war man doch einfach noch nicht so weit
aber wir sind jetzt weiter und
offengestanden sehe ich nicht mehr in
nicht mehr argumente für eine
impfpflicht wir hatten damals eine sehr
niedrige impfquote wir hatten auch nicht
mehr impfstoffe das war auch einer der
gründe warum muss ich mich natürlich
bedeckt gehalten ich kann ja keine
impfpflicht mache ich keinen impfstoff
habe jetzt haben wir ausreichend
impfstoff wir wissen was dem stoff kann
was er nicht kann das ist sicherlich ein
sehr guter impfstoff aber
wir haben ja eine situation erreicht wo
wir ihren hohen anteil der bevölkerung
insbesondere der risikobehafteten
bevölkerungsdaten geimpft haben da kann
man sicherlich noch mehr erreichen aber
es ist ja nicht so dass wir eine
impfquote haben die anderen impfung
entsprechen also wir die impfung über
influenza hätten dann wenn man sich alle
freunde haben im schnitt 50 prozent
quote und nehmen sie denn die
masernimpfung der pflicht ist für alle
kinder die in die kindertagesstätten in
die schulen wollen selbst da kommen wir
gerade über 90 prozent das ist nicht
weit davon entfernt was wir in weiten
teilen der bevölkerung jetzt an krone
schutzmaßnahmen stand also bekommen für
meine auf eine hohe impfquote ohne
dieses am ende wahrscheinlich lahmende
tool der impfpflicht weil ich glaube
nicht wirklich dass sie praxistauglich
umgesetzt werden kann wir sehen es in
österreich die uns in vielen punkt schon
voraussehen was im register
digitalisierung angeht da sind wir weit
hinten dran und die haben gerade
konstatieren müssen das wird so nicht
funktionieren das verzögerung von
einigen monaten geben dann brauchen wir
nicht drüber reden wir hier in
deutschland eine funktionierende
impfpflicht umgesetzt haben hat den
omikron dazu beigetragen vielleicht auch
die frage an sie frau schreiber man muss
ja jetzt nochmal immer wieder auf andere
varianten dann irgendwie reagieren also
wie sehr kann man sozusagen seine
politische entscheidung von der
jeweiligen virus variante abhängig
machen und jetzt sind wir alle sehr
besorgt wegen diesem hohen
infektionszahlen von omikron müssen wir
deshalb wieder ganz grundsätzlich anders
dann zum beispiel über diese impfpflicht
nachdenken oder dann sagen ja zweig ist
dann doch die bessere antwort darauf
also wieso wie flexibel muss man da sein
also ich glaube die varianten sind
wirklich sehr sehr wichtig zu
berücksichtigen und da wissen wir
einfach moment noch nicht was uns noch
bevorsteht wir haben jetzt gesehen dass
omikron sehr viel ansteckender ist also
brauchen wir eigentlich höhere quoten um
eine gute immunität in der bevölkerung
zu erzeugen es kann aber auch sein dass
in zukunft eine noch ansteckende
variante kommt die auch noch
gefährlicher ist die auch noch schwerere
verläufe als dass ich will jetzt nicht
den teufel an die wand malen euch wir
sagen ist wir wissen in diesem lande mir
geschehen eigentlich nie was kommt
insofern bin ich sehr bei peter lotzer
dass man einfach wirklich schauen muss
und vorbereitet sein muss wir haben als
ethikrat die kriterien entwickelt die
ethischen kriterien nach denen wir
meinen wand eine impfpflicht förderlich
ist oder notwendig ist um eben hohe
impfquoten zu erreichen wenn das
wirklich der fall ist müssen aber andere
entscheiden da muss man dann wirklich
die daten parat haben aber man braucht
eben auch diese flexibilität wir haben
auch gesagt man muss immer wieder
überprüfen und muss das immer wieder die
neue datenlage anpassen und das ist also
sehr wichtig ich glaube wir können jetzt
nicht eine entscheidung treffen ja wir
brauchen sie unbedingt in diesem
augenblick und dann ein wir brauchen sie
partout überhaupt nicht sondern man muss
auch in den nächsten monaten schauen wie
sich omikron entwickelt wie sich vor
allem die schweren verläufe entwickeln
ob die krankenhäuser überlastet sind
oder nicht und das sollte dann mit das
haupt entscheidungskriterium dafür sein
ob man noch zusätzliche maßnahmen auch
um die impfquote eben zu erhöhen aber
auf der anderen seite braucht man doch
irgendwo meine langfriststrategie also
dass das finde ich so schwierig weil das
ist ja auch genau das was die bürger so
mühte macht dass man eigentlich nichts
planen kann frank wartenberg ist ja aber
deshalb wäre halt eine pragmatische
lösung gut ich halte die impfpflicht
tatsächlich im moment für politisch
nicht durchsetzbar anhand dessen was ich
da im moment im parlament abspielt weil
die sich eben gegenseitig blockieren und
wenn man jetzt zu einer umfassenden
zweig regelung käme dann würde das ja
auch dazu führen dass auch die
verantwortung die politische
verantwortung recht gleichmäßig verteilt
wäre weil ja auch die länder es wieder
umsetzen und voll ziehen müssten und die
leute hätten auf jeden fall vor augen
langfristig das ganze ist erloschen in
dem moment in dem wir in ein in de
mission lage kommen und das wäre ja
möglich daß man sagt expertenrat der
bundesregierung oder so kann dann sagen
wenn wir die endemische lage also eine
begrenzte sozusagen oder eine beschwerde
von einer de facto regierung hat gesagt
durch die hintertür sei einfach eine
pragmatisch eingeführte impfpflicht also
natürlich kann kann können sich die
leute immer noch entziehen und es gibt
keine sanktionen aber man kann im leben
nicht mehr teilnehmen und kann man kann
beispielsweise wenn man präsenz am
arbeitsplatz hat auch nicht mehr zu
seinem arbeitsplatz gehen sowie die
gesundheits kräfte im krankenhaus er
besser lasse etwas wie bewerten sie
dieses
diesen umgang dass man sagt man man
nutzt die 2g regelung dadurch hat man
halt eben sozusagen zwingt man eine de
facto und menschen sich zu impfen
also die regelung ist mir deswegen
sympathisch die ausdehnung der zwei
regen regeln weil sie sanfter ist als
die unmittelbare und wirkliche
impfpflicht die dann auch mit
staatlichem zwang sich verbindet oder
mit geldbußen oder dergleichen
aber man muss sehen dass sie
die ungeimpften weniger schützt als ein
pflicht weil solange die ungeimpften
oder um im unwilligen die impfung
vermeiden können indem sie einfach
ausweichen sagen dann gehe ich also
nicht ins restaurant nicht ins kino
nicht in das stadion und dergleichen
werden sie sich nicht impfen lassen das
heißt sie sind gefährdet durch das virus
der staat hat aber eine pflicht die
gesundheit aller zu schützen und dieser
fürsorglichen pflicht würde nicht
gerecht wenn er sagt na gut dann lasst
ihr euch nicht impfen aber ihr könnt an
allgemeinem leben nicht mehr so richtig
teilnehmen aber sie bleiben ungeschützt
das reicht eigentlich als staatliche
reaktion nicht aus aber sagen wir haben
ja selber die entscheidung getroffen
dass sie sich nicht schützen lassen
wollen
ja das können sie das wir haben ja
glücklicherweise eine
bundesverfassungsgerichts entscheidungen
die sich mit diesem thema in anderen
zusammenhängen befasst sie haben eine
das recht der selbstbestimmung sie haben
ein recht auf krankheit wie es da heißt
aber das bundesverfassungsgericht gott
sei dank deutlich gesagt nur solange
diese selbstbestimmung nicht auch andere
gefährdet wenn sie andere damit
gefährden und das tun sie als ungeimpfte
in stärkerem maße als als geimpfter weil
sie stärker anstecken können wenn ich
den medizinern glauben darf dann
muss etwas unternommen werden dass diese
gefährdung der anderen reduziert wird
und wenn das nur geht dadurch dass sie
jemanden zur impfung noch strikt dann
noch strenger veranlassen als durch
solche anreize sonst kannst du dich ins
restaurant nicht ins kino und
dergleichen
dann muss das gemacht werden aber was
immer sie wie immer sie reagieren wollen
sie müssen die instrumente schaffen sie
müssen sie parat haben es kann doch noch
viel schlimmer uns geht es ja relativ
gut es kann doch viel schlimmer noch
kommen wir können noch sehr viel mehr
tote sie müssen doch die instrumente
bereit halten um dann zu sagen jetzt
tritt das und das in kraft aber ist das
wichtigste instrument wäre ja wirklich
hohe impfquote herr gassen und da müsste
man ja dann noch mal mehr für thun
letztendlich also lässt sich gefährdete
ungeimpfte sich selbst und nicht den
geimpften das muss man einfach so als
die gefährdung nicht tatsächlich bei dem
der die impfung verweigern und ich habe
nicht wirklich die fantasie dass eine
impfpflicht dergestalt wie sie
diskutiert wird hardcore impfverweigerer
zur impfung bringt die werden im zweifel
den bußgeldbescheid abwarten und den
beklagen also da wird wahrscheinlich
keinen impfgegner mehr durchgeimpft
deshalb glaube ich tatsächlich wir
müssen versuchen argumentativ noch die
zu überzeugen die es zu überzeugen gibt
und würden sie denn sagen man muss
ungeimpfte all das ist richtig dass man
um gm wieder anders behandelt dass sie
weniger rechte dann haben es das richtig
so ich kann das ich kann das nicht
beantworten will ich auch gar nicht und
es letztlich eine politische
entscheidung
ich würde als mediziner jedem dazu raten
der erwachsenen ist sich impfen zu
lassen so das ist alles andere ist eine
individuelle entscheidung und es gibt
eben das recht auf kranken es gibt
genauso das recht dass patienten von
behandlungen verweigern die offenkundig
im zweifel auch zum tode führen es
erleben wäre und ich habe es als
unfähige auch erleben müssen das müssen
sie akzeptieren
insofern glaube ich dieses album sorgen
der anspruch den der staat hier
formuliert und den er nicht einlösen
wird und nicht einlösen kann finde ich
schwierig und ich der hilft ich glaube
einfach es hilft uns nichts am ende des
tages möchte ich eine möglichst hohe
impfquoten und ich sehe nicht dass die
impfpflicht diese impfquote bringt und
ich sehe auch nicht dass das aktuelle
politische handeln die impfquote
besonders fördern und wenn ich da bin
ich schon hier bei fockbek wenn man sagt
wir wollen wir fördern und wollen alles
unter der impfpflicht machen ist zweig
das relativ einfacher tool wie ich
möglichst gerade die menschen die sagen
das wird dann einfach lässt sich lasse
mich impfen die grundsätzlichen
impfgegner werden sie durch keine
maßnahme überzeugender müssen sind
impfzwang machen müssen die zwangs
vorführen das ist ja wohl nicht
ernsthaft vorstellbar also kommen wir an
einem gewissen punkt wo wir nicht drüber
com bußgeld hin oder her und von daher
glaube ich ist zweig sicherlich
eleganter und wahrscheinlich auch
effektiver wenn es denn umgesetzt würde
die frage ist ob die politik der durch
vertrauen aufbauen oder verliert frau
schreiber was würden sie was werden
ihrer meinung nach wenn man sagt dass
impfen ist das wichtigste nach wie vor
wir müssen mehr menschen müssen diese
eben quote erhöhen aber andererseits hat
jeder auch das recht eben sich nicht
impfen zu lassen also wie muss die
müsste die politik da ihrer meinung nach
agieren um halt eben gerade auch in
einer zeit die sich wo sich dauernd
dinge ändern trotzdem vertrauen zu
bekommen
also es ist so dass es auf jeden fall
wünschenswert ist dass die maßnahmen die
zu einer freiwilligen impfung motivieren
dass die verbessert werden ja dass da
mehr ganz schon ganz auch darüber
gesprochen dass wir im termine anbieten
dass man in die kieze geht dass man mit
verschiedenen gruppen und spricht und
versuchte überzeugungsarbeit zu leisten
auf der anderen seite möchte ich aber
trotzdem noch mal ganz kurz darauf
konnten zu sprechen kommt dass wir hier
wirklich nicht nur eine eigengefährdung
es ist ja tatsächlich so dass wir auch
eine fremdgefährdung haben das heißt für
den e card war so dass wirklich das
ausschlaggebende kriterium ist dass man
wenn man ungeimpft ist man auch andere
personen wirklich immer stärkeren maße
gefährdet entweder durch die direkte
ansteckung oder das was wir im dezember
gesehen haben dadurch dass dann durch
ungeimpfte vorwiegend intensivstation
überfüllt werden und dann auch andere
patienten nicht mehr behandelt werden
können und das dürfen wir nicht außer
acht lassen also wenn wir wirklich eine
situation hätten wo es nur um die eigene
gesundheit geht dann wäre eine
impfpflicht
dadurch die meisten meiner kollegen
integrierten zustimmen nicht zu
rechtfertigen das ausschlaggebende
kriterium ist aber wirklich dass es
indirekt diese fremdgefährdung gibt dass
man mit dieser entscheidung eben auch
nachteile für andere schafft dass man
andere gefährdet und das ist nicht
hinnehmbar da ist dann irgendwann der
punkt erreicht wenn wirklich das
gesundheitssystem so stark gefährdet ist
dass man dann doch irgendwie eingreifen
muss und so lange es keine milderen
mittel gibt ja zwei gewehre ein milderes
mittel wenn wir damit zurechtkommen
jetzt mit omikron wäre das wunderbar
aber dann so lange es diese milderen
mittel nicht gäbe zu diesem zeitpunkt
müsste dann entschieden werden also dort
so umgehend ist dann geht es die
entscheidung des ethikrates zu verstehen
dass dann die impfpflicht auch ein
legitimes mittel ist wir sind aber alle
dafür dass es wichtig ist ein
einfacheres besseres mittel zu finden
vorher solange das möglich ist sofern es
wirksam ist ja weil wir das ja jetzt
auch eigentlich brauchen also du bist
die impfpflicht wirkt herr gast was
denken sie bis wann wann würde denn eine
impfpflicht überhaupt wirken wenn sie
jetzt meine zeit in der politik dass man
im februar noch nicht zu einer
entscheidung kommen kann und das ist
frühestens im märz irgendwann es mitte
märz das ist also relevant würde sie im
zweifel tatsächlicher allenfalls für die
nächste winter welle wenn es die noch
gäbe und wenn es eine virusvariante ist
für die wird einen impfstoff hätten das
sind viele wenns und abers also mit
einer nikon das glaube ich können wir
uns abschminken
die messe ist gesungen diese welle kommt
und die wird auch keine impfpflicht mehr
aufhalten und jetzt kann man natürlich
die ketzerische frage stellen würde eine
impfpflicht mit welcher möglichen
impfquoten erhöhen überhaupt was ändern
und da sind sicher zweifel angebracht
wenn man sich die impfquoten aktuell
anschaut ist da noch ein bisschen luft
drin aber ob das nun den den
entscheidenden unterschied macht
impfpflicht versus eine zweig kampagne
kombiniert mit einer aufklärungskampagne
das ist sicherlich dann ein bisschen
falschen des kaisers bart also rein
praktisch umsetzbar glaube ich nicht vor
herbst und das ist wäre sehr sportlich
halte ich auch schon für fast nicht
realistisch der haben sie den eindruck
dass die politik das aussitzen will und
wartet dann bis omikron sich so
entwickelt hat dass wir in diese
sogenannte in dänische lage kommen ich
glaube so strategisch sind die im moment
gar nicht dass die leute hier sitzen das
aus das ist ja tatsächlich eher so dass
die in ein noch größeres problem rein
schlittern weil uns im moment die zeit
auch wirklich davon läuft also scholz
hat ja gesagt er wollte das im februar
anderes gesetz der haken dran gemacht
wird jetzt ist klar wir sind auf jeden
fall im märz bevor eventuell an
eingesetzt an dass ich noch nicht glaube
weil ich weil ich die politischen
mehrheiten nicht sehe einen haken
gemacht werden könnte er gibt es ja auch
so an den bundestag jetzt ab genauer
gibt es dann im bundestag ab dass genau
dieses schwarze peter spiel keiner
möchte im endeffekt wirklich dafür
verantwortlich sein und wenn dann im
märz also im besten falle im märz ein
solches gesetz in kraft trete dann
müssten ja noch fristen drin sein müsste
man sagen entweder die impfpflicht wird
erst in drei monaten scharf gestellt
oder man sagt die sanktionen werden also
im pflicht gilt ab sofort und die
sanktionen werden das den drei monaten
scharf gestellt weil man ja dann den
leuten noch mal die gelegenheit geben
muss die impfpflicht auch tatsächlich zu
erfüllen und dann sind wir tatsächlich
dann wären wir tatsächlich im sommer und
dann könnte man natürlich sagen die
leute lassen sich jetzt impfen und
vielleicht hilft es dann im herbst für
die nächste welle und es wäre aber viel
besser eben eine andere verbindlichkeit
fürs impfen zu schaffen weil dass wir
die impfungen brauchen zweifeln ja
wirklich nur wenige dran also dass wir
eine wirklich hohe impfquoten brauchen
und die sollte auch erreicht werden wenn
im sommer die zahlen runter gehen weil
es ja so ist wir wissen nicht ob noch
eine variante kopf das heißt man kann
doch gar nicht aussetzen man wird eine
man wird eine man wird eine einen hebel
finden müssen um die impfung in
deutschland verbindlicher zu machen und
da müsste die politik einfach mal
ehrlich darüber diskutieren die debatte
im moment ist wirklich nicht ehrlich was
wäre denn ehrlich ja ehrlich wäre dass
man also dass das alle farbe bekennen
und also das dann tatsächlich die
regierung wenn die opposition nicht
mitmacht muss die regierung hat einen
gesetzentwurf vorlegen und über den muss
dann abgestimmt werden und dann kann man
auch sehen ob die union tatsächlich bei
ihrem thema sie möchte der impfpflicht
haben nur show gemacht hat noch besser
wäre es wenn die politischen parteien
sagen würden wir sind in einer lage in
dieser nation in der man irgendwie mal
zusammen rücken sollte und gemeinsam an
einem strang ziehen hat der
unionsfraktionsvorsitzende ich noch mal
gesagt man es muss unsere nationalen
konsens sollte es geben könnte man damit
anfangen also ich meine das ist das ist
das ist das was ich mit verlogen meine
also der sagt dann man braucht einen
nationalen konsens ist aber selber nicht
bereit irgendeinen schritt richtung
konsens zu gehen und für die ampel gilt
das gleiche die sehen sie haben keine
eigene mehrheit und anstatt dann auch
offen zu sagen wir haben keine eigene
mehrheit wir sind auf die hilfe der
union angewiesen und er wird gehen wir
jetzt auf die union zu das passiert eben
auch nicht wenn wird und so einfach
gesagt ja gut dann machen deshalb
fraktions offen es gab eine große
mehrheit bei der impfpflicht für
angestellte oder für personal im
krankenhaus also für die alle in den
gesundheitsbereich und jetzt gibt es ja
auch die frage macht das denn italien
hat das eingeführte nebenpflicht für
über 50 jährige pastor laster wie
wichtig oder wie sinnvoll wäre es dass
man diese impfpflicht einschränkt und
wie wir rechtlich oder wie viel sicherer
wäre das dann dass man das umsetzen kann
weil es nur für bestimmte gruppen gilt
die gefahr ist immer wenn sie solche
altersgrenzen setzen dass das gegriffene
zahlen sind und sie nicht wirklich
belegen können dass das wirklich die
hochrisikogruppen sind die sicher
schützen wollen und auch gegen ihren
eigenen willen schützen wollen weil sie
es besser wissen
das ist sozusagen eine mögliches mittel
um weil nur teile der bevölkerung
dadurch betroffen sind wenn noch große
teile die akzeptanz zu erhöhen wenn sich
eine allgemeine impfpflicht für alle
sozusagen ab 5 oder zwölf oder 15 jahren
aussprechen
ist diese rolle dass das nicht
akzeptiert wird dass der widerstand
wächst natürlich größer also so verstehe
ich dass ich halte es nicht vernünftig
da solche alters regeln einzuführen ich
sympathisiere sehr mit dem was hier in
der runde vorgeschlagen worden ist eine
ausdehnung der zweig regelung die
überlegung von professor schreiber
gefallen mir sehr gut und auch der
hinweis darauf auf die fremdgefährdung
durch nicht kämpfen das muss alles
bedacht werden und dann müssen sie ihre
schlüsse draus ziehen nur das was sie
nicht tun können ist die hände in den
schoß legen und oder so wie es gesagt
worden ist also unehrlich zu debattieren
das geht nicht sie müssen endlich in
irgendeiner richtung
handeln und auch aber das tun sie davon
also es gibt auch jede menge mal
unbeliebte maßnahmen die die politik
getroffen hat also es ist ja nicht so
dass die politik jetzt nicht gehandelt
hätte ja aber das sind die die impfung
ist das eigen das einzige jedenfalls
nach medizinischen stand das einzige was
wirklich hilft das was wir sonst haben
wir jene abstand masken und dergleichen
das sind doch nur flankierende maßnahmen
die dafür sorgen dass es nicht noch
schlimmer kommt wirklich bekämpfen
können sie die pandemie jedoch nur mit
wirkstoffen und nicht mit diesen
sekunden maßnahmen also da ist es gut
dass da viel gemacht worden ist und
weiter gemacht wird aber es reicht eben
nicht aus sie brauchen mehr sie brauchen
die medizin und da muss gehandelt werden
und da wirklich gehandelt dann könnte
man aber auch sagen frau schreiber nur
weil die politik ist nicht geschafft hat
die impfkampagne so gut aufzusetzen das
wirklich ist dass es eine höhere
impfquote gibt wie sie zum beispiel in
spanien gibt schränken wir so ein
starkes grundrecht 1
ist das eine richtige abwehr gut
also wenn man es mit anderen ländern
vergleicht dann muss man sagen gibt es
auch andere hintergrund er sich geben in
dem man gerne beispiel portugal wo man
erst vor einigen jahrzehnten
kinderimpfungen eingeführt hat so man
wirklich gesehen hat wie impfungen dazu
führen dass kinder nicht mehr versterben
dort ist die akzeptanz der impfung sehr
viel höher und dann kommt man auch
schneller zu gehören impfen trotzdem
muss man halt einfach sehen dass man
wirklich die impfung auch also dass wir
ab maßnahmen haben die wirkung da würde
ich wirklich zustimmen das ist ja ganz
klar und wir brauchen also ich sehe
einfach nicht dass wir langfristig um
also ohne impfung auskommen insofern
mischungen den verbrechern die wieder
ohne impfung ist klar dass wir dann
langfristig nicht ohne impfung aus die
frage ist ja ob wir ohne ihn pflicht
auskommen
das ist man das muss man also ich würde
sagen dass die impfpflicht wenn ich mal
ganz kurz auf den punkt zurück kommen
kann mit dem mit dem alter das ist schon
auch aus ethischer sicht rechtfertigt es
besser rechtfertigt da ist er also
risikogruppen zu impfen und dort zeigen
die zahlen in dieser pandemie hat schon
dass die älteren besonders gefährdet
sind ja wir wissen dass einfach die
anteil an schweren erkrankung und auch
die todeszahlen sind deutlich höher die
todes quoten bei der älteren bevölkerung
insofern wäre das ein pragmatischer weg
zu sagen wenn wir jetzt die überlastung
der gesundheits des gesundheitssystems
verhindern möchten und eine ausweitung
haben dass man dann auch bei diesen
vokabeln gruppen beginnt das finde ich
jetzt gar nicht also man auf den
kommentar von herrn basterds dazu kommen
dass nicht gar nicht so abwegig ich
finde ich unterstütze diese dieses
vorgehen
besser als erwarten sie da noch was zu
sagen ja es ist sicher besser als gar
nichts und wenn das akzeptiert werden
oder von der bevölkerung so ab 50 oder
60 oder 45 wäre ich glücklich das ist
besser als gar nichts aber es passiert
ja nichts in der richtung bisher
vorschläge liegen auf dem tisch aber es
passiert nicht und wenn gesagt wird für
alle schaffen wir das nicht das ist
nicht durchsetzbar weil die akzeptanz
nicht da ist und wir wollen das nicht in
ordnung aber dann macht das und macht es
schnell daneben für die aber oft sehr
angenehm aber nach trotzdem würde es
auch wenn es schnell entschieden wird
jetzt ja nicht helfen im moment bei der
pandemie bekämpfung der gassen glauben
sie dass es etwas helfen würde bei der
ganzen diskussion wenn wir jetzt
mitbekommen dass die parteien da es
nicht schaffen sich so schnell zu
einigen und wir stolz ja immer sagt dass
dieses land sei nicht gespalten auf der
anderen seite sehen wir dauernd jede
menge proteste gegen die korona
maßnahmen wäre die impfpflicht da ein
beschleuniger in richtung spaltung oder
würdest das alles vielleicht auch ein
bisschen unternehmen ich glaube da
gibt's ja unterschiedlich auf also ich
persönlich hätte er sorge dass ich das
eher adidas für die radikalisierenden
dann einfacher wird auch nicht radikale
menschen sozusagen zu demonstrieren ich
glaube politik wird das nicht
entscheiden aber das virus wird hier ein
machtwort sprechen ich gehe fest davon
aus wer sich nicht impfen lässt wird
sich bis zum sommer wahrscheinlich
ohnehin infizieren insofern ist das der
deshalb haben wir die zeit ist eine
müßige diskussion fast eine
phantomdiskussion
eine impfpflicht für den zweiten
jahrestag ins auge zu fassen bis dahin
ist die messe wahrscheinlich gesungen
wer sich nicht impfen lässt wird sich
mit hoher wahrscheinlichkeit infizieren
und von daher kann man eigentlich nur
alles daran setzen jetzt noch möglichst
viele menschen zur impfung zu motivieren
oder die anderen sagen dann ja es wird
da ist ja nicht so schlimm
das ist wäre dann die individuelle
entscheidung und wir können da nur
hoffen dass omikron tatsächlich die
milden verläufe macht weil ich glaube
mit allen maßnahmen die wir zum einen
schaffen es im günstigsten fall die
ausbreitung zu bremsen das zeigen die
erfahrungen aus den anderen ländern und
von daher glaube ich ist dass im herbst
ein rückblick in der diskussion wie
würden sie es beurteilen was das
sozusagen
radikalisiert dass eine gruppe oder
hilft das auch so zu sagen dass alles so
ein bisschen zu befrieden so nach dem
motto ok jetzt ist es eben so dass ich
mich in dem moment also zwei dinge dass
ich denke dass menschen die sich
radikalisieren lassen sich auch durch
andere dinge radikalisieren lassen
würden also wir haben ja auch die kita
proteste die mich sehr an das erinnern
was wir heute moment auf der straße
sehen und das interessante ist ja dass
wir im moment proteste haben als würde
die impfpflicht tatsächlich eingeführt
die impfpflicht wird nicht eingeführt
also diese proteste sind ja eigentlich
antizipiert das sind ja leute die gegen
die impfpflicht auf die straße gehen und
deshalb gehe ich jetzt mal davon aus
wenn die politik durchziehen würde das
die proteste gar nicht so viel stärker
noch mal anstellen würden es gibt
vielleicht noch mal ein peak aber es
wäre jetzt nicht also ich glaube die die
welle der proteste die haben wir schon
erreicht und das problem ist wirklich
das lavieren der politik und je länger
es dauert desto größer desto mehr
menschen bekommen zweifeln und desto
mehr schließen desto mehr haben
rechtsradikale die darauf ihre suppe
kochen auch die möglichkeit
menschen anzusprechen die normalerweise
nicht radikal sind also wenn wir schon
letzten sommer sozusagen eine
impfpflicht gehabt hätten wäre
wahrscheinlich in der höheren quote ein
ganzer schritt weiter gewesen und wenn
man sich das getraut hätte und da hat
man nicht
okay gut dann einfach kurze frage zum
schluss an alle wird die impfpflicht
kommen was ist ihre prognose daher
besser lasse
ich frage mich traurig zu sehen was die
politiker machen nachdem sie so
zögerlich sind ich würde mir wünschen
dass sie sich dafür entscheiden
aber gleichzeitig versuchen die
bevölkerung zu überreden zu überzeugen
davon dass es sinnvoll ungeachtet der
impfpflicht es die impfpflicht kann ja
gelten trotzdem kann ich mich ja auch
freiwillig noch vor fristablauf wurde
gleich
dazu kurz frau schreiber was ist ihre
prognose da wird es eine geben
ich frage da keine prognose ich hoffe
aber dass die entscheidung wie auch
immer sie ausfällt nicht rein politisch
getroffen wird sondern wirklich auf
grundlage von einer guten abwägung dass
man sich alle argumente anschaut und
dann gewissenhaft entscheidet ok vielen
dank eine allgemeine impfpflicht wird
meiner meinung nach nicht kommen weil es
keine politischen mehrheiten dafür gibt
aber ich das noch kompromisse kommen das
halte ich für möglich ich glaube wenn
die politik die rational an das thema
herangeht es keine allgemeine
impfpflicht geben okay wir sind gespannt
und werden sicherlich noch öfters hier
darüber diskutieren je nachdem wie die
entwicklung in der politik ist jetzt
folgt für nix der tag mit thomas bade
ihnen noch einen schönen abend bis dann
[Musik]